non è facile salire su questo palco
subito dopo lo speaker che abbiamo visto
va bene ci provo
mi chiamo leandro agrò è effettivamente
sono il primo designer che oggi è qui
sul palco e quindi non vedrete grandi
tecnologie o conquista dello spazio ma
magari qualcosa che ha che fare col
mondo delle idee e soprattutto per i
comportamenti
la storia che vi racconto oggi a che
fare con la internet degli oggetti è la
definizione che usiamo per il prossimo
passo di evoluzione della rete internet
e a che fare con il contributo che il
design può dare alla internet degli
oggetti è una storia sostanzialmente
divisa in tre atti tecnologia salute e
design tecnologia
beh oggi vediamo cose incredibili ma io
voglio partire veramente da lontano
perché se ci sono due foto in una delle
due immagini e beh sono io scegliete voi
quale potrebbe essere quella giusta e la
foto è stata scattata oltre quarant'anni
fa in sicilia e se io penso in quell
universo
immaginario della mia fanciullezza la
cosa che mi colpisce è quanto fosse più
disponibile l'accesso alla fantascienza
che non l'accesso al accesa alla scienza
che invece era difficile lontana insomma
e forse per questo le prime letture
davvero appassionanti ma era un po più
grande insomma nella foto hanno avuto a
che fare con la robotica la robotica
l'ho incontrata come probabilmente molti
di noi attraverso isaac asimov il mondo
raccontato da asimov aveva una
elegantissima coerenza basata
sostanzialmente su tre semplici leggi le
leggi della robotica sono delle leggi di
buon senso sostanzialmente la prima per
esempio dice che un robot non può fare
male non può creare del danno neanche
con la propria in azione a un essere
umano la seconda dice
deve obbedire agli esseri umani però
almeno che questa obbedienza non
contraddica la prima legge e la terza
legge sostanzialmente dice che un robot
deve avere cura di se deve proteggere la
propria esistenza
almeno che questo non contraddica la
seconda e la prima legge
al di là dell'eleganza da scrittore con
cui questa legge è formulata e al di là
della enorme coerenza che dall'universo
raccontato da asimov la cosa che oggi da
designer mi colpisce è che queste leggi
parlano di specifiche tecniche antico
quanto deve essere alto un robot quanta
forza deve avere per un essere
aggressivo per essere accettabile
parlano dei suoi comportamenti e questo
dal mio punto di vista è l'anima più
profonda del design
l'altra domanda oggi da designer e
quella è sì ma come il successo tutto
ciò come come sull umanità rendersi
conto quando ha bisogno di leggi del
genere
e regolamenta un intero universo è di
solito le leggi di questo tipo avvengono
dopo dei disastri ecco cioè sono
reattive in qualche modo ciò che va
storto e invece abbiamo un'opportunità
perché la intende gli oggetti e oggi è
la possibilità di influenzarla
attraverso il design è adesso e
credo sia necessario a questo punto
avendo la citata più volte dare una
qualche definizione di internet degli
oggetti la più generica e forse la più
semplice che mi viene in mente è
semplicemente quella che dice
sentiamo la pulsione da podista del
mercato ma anche al punto se le persone
di sostituire gli oggetti che abbiamo e
che sono non connessi con oggetti che
sono connessi
approfittando di questa opportunità di
sostituzione per aggiungere qualità
senzienti sensori che ci daranno la
possibilità di fare cose nuove o di fare
cose più accuratamente o di avere nuovi
modelli di business
ne abbiamo appena avuto una grandissima
dimostrazione e ogni come dire
evoluzione a un suppongo m piace pensare
in questo sono d'accordo con rafia lei
da jean che l'ha disegnato progettato e
voluto produrre sul mercato che il fomc
di questa intende gli oggetti tutto
sommato sia il nabaztag questo simpatico
coniglio con le orecchie semoventi
capace di riprodurre dei suoni che erano
stati registrati da qualcun altro su un
altro comune rafi me ne regala uno e io
ci giocai con mia figlia che allora
aveva due anni
e l'ha fatto
come dire il fatto emotivo la capacità
emotiva che aveva col coni gli
attraversamenti e le orecchie le luci la
riproduzione dei suoni ha fatto sì che
fosse subito bene accetto ma questo non
ha impedito del giro più o meno di un
anno di finire in un cassetto di finire
dimenticato beh anche per onorare il
coraggio imprenditoriale di rafi a me
piace dire che un esercito di 250.000
conigli è stato sacrificato nel
tentativo di capire le dinamiche della
internet degli oggetti di capire che
cosa avremmo fatto con questa nuova fase
di evoluzione e se il numero 250 mila mi
sembra un numero importante beh
quest'altro numero 50 miliardi di
oggetti connessi entro il 2020
beh dovrebbe darvi la scossa
e per cercare di tracciare una curva per
capire dove siamo rispetto a questa
crescita la domanda potrebbe essere fare
un paragone con la quantità di esseri
umani che abbiamo sulla terra quando
accadrà che il numero degli oggetti
connessi che costruiamo supererà il
numero degli esseri umani è già accaduto
è già accaduto nel 2008 e essendo già
fase tre anni tre anni sono una quantità
di tempo così imponente da differenziare
per esempio internet 3 google da quella
post google quella pre facebook da
quella post facebook e abbiamo idea oggi
di che cosa voglia dire questo genere di
impatto
e qui per vedere le cose un po più da
distante un po più dall'alto e cercare
in qualche modo di comprenderle vi
chiedo di venire un attimo in orbita con
me e tutto sommato di provare a guardare
il mondo
davvero da vicino
il termine che vorrei usare questo penso
che sia evidente a tutti che le migliori
qualità umane la più grande capacità di
design la tecnologia più rilevante che
abbiamo adoperato è quella che abbiamo
adoperato per la conquista dello spazio
però oggi abbiamo circa 16 mila corpi di
dimensioni di circa 10 centimetri che
chiamiamo space junk e ho saputo oggi da
fonte diretta che gli astronauti
della della base spaziale che abbiamo
visto oggi in orbita bene più o meno
cinque volte l'anno incorrono in un
allarme perché uno degli oggetti che che
determina la space junk e per loro
pericoloso bene se 250.000 conigli sono
diventati beautiful junk così
rapidamente io mi chiedo che cosa possa
succedere a 50 miliardi di oggetti se
questi non saranno progettati almeno
bene come quello che noi mandiamo in
orbita
per entrare un po più
nella qualità di progettazione che noi
siamo prenderò a riferimento quello che
tutti percepiamo come uno dei settori
come dire più tutelati legalmente più
tutelati dal punto di vista anche
dell'attenzione che si mette perché a
che fare con la nostra salute ogni
giorno
ma il mondo della caire della salute non
è separato da quello che sta succedendo
fuori la progressiva digitalizzazione di
tutto ciò che riguarda il nostro
quotidiano ci dà una incremento di
velocità veramente molto importante oggi
ne possiamo studiare attraverso che so
il google body browser del corpo umano
con una tutto sommato facilità e con una
precisione e quando io ero al liceo era
semplicemente fantascienza la stessa
fantascienza dei libri di asimov niente
di diverso
se pensiamo che la medicina perché più
tutelata perché più tranquilla perché
più prudente sia distante dai fenomeni
di internet in generale beh non è poi
così vero pences lightning ii come
facebook ma condivide dati di medicina
la geo medicina è un'applicazione che
tutto sommato se non esistesse google
maps probabilmente non sarebbe stata
immaginata e tutto questo sta cambiando
l'ulker e sta scambiando l'intera
società
è un dispositivo portatile che misura le
nostre condizioni mediche in tempo reale
continuamente e alla porta ce lo avremo
molto presto
questo in particolare è stata annunciata
la tac conferenze sarà in commercio a
gennaio
ebbene
tutto questo mi porta a dire che
anche il mondo più prudente nella
intende gli oggetti tutto sommato sta
proliferando una quantità di oggetti una
mia una biodiversità così bassa da
sembrare quasi anzi una invasione di
oggetti che si prenderanno cura di noi
fisso già sentendo meglio da questo
punto di vista perché so che sarò
tutelato ma il prossimo passo non sarà
quello di una umanità avanzata o
un'umanità amplificata di nano robotica
e di cose che appunto ci sembrano ancora
da fantascienza il prossimo passo è già
accaduto e lo troviamo in qualunque
negozio questa è la apple store di new
york e quel bancone sono prodotti
medicali di fascia consumer tutto sotto
i 100 dollari ma ti puoi misurare la
pressione sanguigna poi tenere sotto
controllo il tuo comportamento parlo dal
punto di vista medico e da questo punto
di vista si sta completamente incrinando
quella che era la relazione immediata e
piena di infrastrutture piena di
barriere tra per esempio medico e
paziente
uno dei più grandi progetti legati al
mondo della salute negli ultimi anni è
stato google health monitoriamo la
salute del pianeta
ebbene questo progetto è stato chiuso e
stato chiuso qualche mese fa e
secondo la persona che per un anno e
mezzo lo ha portato avanti erano
bosworth il motivo e
non era abbastanza sociale ed è strano
perché insomma a che fare con dati
veramente critici quindi essere sociali
non dovrebbe essere la cosa più
importante ma lo stesso giorno hanno
chiuso anche questa auto progetto che il
google energy metre il google energy
meter si poneva l'obiettivo davvero
fantastico di ridurre i consumi
energetici del pianeta e per questo cosa
bisognava fare passava misurare i
consumi di ognuno in realtà tutto questo
non è sufficiente
non è sufficiente perché per avere un
cambiamento globale noi dobbiamo
coinvolgere le persone
e a questo serve al design
io ho passato gli ultimi anni a
progettare alcune bizzarrie sensori di
co2 che prendono il dato di
concentrazione quindi del dl della co2
puntuale e lo spediscono sulla rete a
cosa serve serve perché per esempio
la granularità di queste le textures ci
danno una mappa di dove la co2 è
prodotta non solo di dove distribuita
oppure progettare coccodrilli usb zeppi
di sensori alcuni mesi che collegandosi
in tempo reale con i social network
diventavano un'estensione di gioco e
abbiamo progettato anche delle cose che
abbiamo chiamato come questo social
energy meter per l'appunto monitorare i
consumi e cambiare le abitudini delle
persone ma le abitudini e le persone
hanno bisogno di stimoli sociali e
questo che si chiama social energy meter
non a caso ha la caratteristica di
ridarmi come feedback non solo il mio
consumo in tempo reale ma anche il
consumo di un benchmark è che io ho
scelto io come utente quindi per me è
significativo magari sono le persone che
vivono nel mio palazzo o magari sono
quattro amici sparpagliati nei quattro
continenti
in ogni caso quando il loro consumo
medio ed è indicato da un colore è
migliore del mio consumo medio beh so
chi è il cattivo e balzani e andare a
spegnere la luce o fare qualcosa di
questo genere
la crowdsourced ecologi l'ecologia dal
basso per esempio utilizzando un
banalissime phone l'ecologia che può
avere a che fare con la texon del rumore
le mappe del rumore su una cosa che
possiamo affrontare ogni giorno e fanno
parte di un universo ampio che sta
collegando ogni palazzo pianta
automobile tutto il resto alla rete
internet per me questo non è altro che
mettere delle anime di software nelle
cose e queste anime di software sono
molto simili al disegno di gaia e questo
sta avvenendo così rapidamente che
ritengo che sia utile e urgente avere un
piano
e questo è un pezzo del piano sono le
leggi del design che immodestamente sto
cercando di promuovere promuoverle
perché sostanzialmente sono abbastanza
stanco di avere un'auto z di sensori
così riservata da un dilemma niente al
mio telefonino
o avere un telefonino che si collega con
qualunque cosa ma mai e poi mai partire
parlerebbe collauto questi due settori
dell'industria devono parlarsi perché il
contro stiamo ovviamente pagando noi e
usare il design vuol dire e torna ad
asimov
occuparsi dei comportamenti quali
comportamenti ci servono oggi questa è
la proposta sono tre leggi il numero non
è casuale la prima dice che gli oggetti
dovrebbero essere in grado di conoscere
delle storie la storia del loro passato
come sono stati fatti da dove vengono e
la storia del loro futuro ok finito
ciclo di vita come lo smog come lo
valorizzò come rientra nel giro e non
diventa space junk e ho bisogno anche
questi oggetti
che questi oggetti siano connessi
ho bisogno che questi oggetti siano
senzienti cioè non un navigatore
satellitare una mappa e un orologio che
abbiano la pretesa di condurmi ovunque
ma qualcosa come un'auto che abbiamo
visto oggi che esplora il mondo
circostante quindi è capace di
conoscerlo in qualche modo e abbiamo
anche bisogno che questi oggetti siano
sociali è fondamentale ma sociali vuol
dire che partecipano alle relazioni
umane vuol dire sostanzialmente che
questi oggetti hanno la capacità di
comunicare nella stessa rete che siamo
noi perché persone e macchine devono
condividere la stessa rete queste sono
penso le condizioni le caratteristiche i
comportamenti che ci potrebbero oggi
aiutare a progettare degli oggetti
migliori e fanno la stessa differenza da
ieri di quanto l'era industriale quindi
gli oggetti che progettano noi stessi
perché utilizzando un oggetto veniamo
influenzati nel nostro modo di essere e
diventano degli oggetti che sfruttano
fondamentalmente la loro capacità
proprio
mutevole e come dire
mutante di essere diversi attraverso il
layer digitale per fare un piccolo
switch per me fondamentale passare da
essere la conseguenza di oggetti che
usiamo ad essere probabilmente la
conseguenza degli oggetti che
progettiamo e la differenza per me è
l'aspirazione umana
ho finito